So what does it mean for this symbol to
emerge from the feminine symbol,
let's say,
to emerge from chaos?
Well,
this picture,
this is a picture of Venus,
the goddess of love,
right?
And so I cut this picture out of a
larger picture and it's Venus
manifesting yourself in a transcendent
space in the sky in the same way that
Christ did in the previous
representation and she has raised coming
off her.
And there's all these men who are nights
kneeling in front of the image.
Well,
what does that mean?
it means that men use the image of
female perfection to motivate
themselves.
And that's exactly right.
That's precisely what they do.
You see that in the Tom Sawyer story.
So Tom Sawyer is about 12 years old and
he's still hanging around with his
friends like huck Finn and this word
girl moves across the street,
becky and she comes out and he's struck
by her for the first time in his life,
something's changed and the first thing
he does is hot pop on a picket fence and
show off and balance in front of her.
And he's saying,
well,
look at me,
look at me.
I'm,
he's like the male bowerbird building
something beautiful so the female will
approve of it and it's,
it's motivation,
you know?
And that's something that I think modern
women don't really understand about men.
They don't understand that at least to
the degree that males are uncorrupted
and not better because of being
rejected,
they're doing everything they can to
kneel before the eternal image of the
feminine
and try to make themselves worthy as the
chivalry story.
Right?
That's what you should encourage your
partner.
So and so out of chaos emerges this
first form.
It's the feminine form.
It's partly the form that represents
novelty as such so and,
and on one hand its promise,
on the other hand it's threat that you
wouldn't believe.
And I don't know because I don't know.
I don't understand the situation with
women as well as I understand the
situation with men.
Obviously being a man,
but I don't know if women have any idea
how paralyzing they are to especially
young men,
a large,
very large number of my clinical
clients,
but also young men I've talked to in
general are absolutely terrified of
women because they're terrified of being
rejected and the terror exist in precise
proportion to the retraction,
to the woman,
which is a horrible paradoxical
situation to be in.
It's often why man makes such fools of
themselves in front of women that
they're attracted to.
It's because first of all,
they don't see the woman that they're
attracted to because what the hell do
they know about her?
They don't see her as an individual.
They see her as the manifestation of a
judgmental ideal and then it's only in
establishing the relationship with the
actual woman that they can start
differentiating between the judgmental
ideal and the actual individual woman.
And that also requires the sacrifice and
the sacrifice is
you never can have an ideal woman.
So to have a relationship with any
woman,
you have to sacrifice the relationship,
the ideal woman,
and you have to see the individual woman
and separate her from the ideal,
and that's the same thing that happens
to the hero in sleeping beauty,
right?
He sees the evil queen who actually
turns into the dragon of chaos and it's
not until he can,
he can defeat her,
that he can establish a relationship
with the actual princess.
And that's exactly the case.
I had a wonderful my clients who ran
this men's group,
which was quite interesting.
One of the things they had initiates do,
which was very intelligent,
was to go out and ask 50 women in one
day for their phone numbers.
Why politely,
properly you don't want.
It wasn't.
It wasn't a,
it was a game,
but it wasn't a stupid game.
And the idea was get over your fear of
rejection and how do you do that by
encountering it continually and
continually and continually so that
you're no longer paralyzed by this.